malgré le froid et la pluie plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont déplacées
pour une pro quand un peu particulière
un déstockage massif des jeux de société
nous on cherche des jeux pour nos petits
enfants des jeux pour adultes aussi des
jeux comme penny pepper island
alors on veut pas le dire parce que
sinon organisé par la maison des jeux de
touraine
l'association se séparent pour des
raisons financières d'une partie de sa
collection et de son mobilier
désormais les bénévoles et les adhérents
se retrouvent à la ludothèque les rives
du cher
on avait déjà une bibliothèque à cet
endroit mais là on va en avoir plusieurs
salles mais au total on réduit notre
surface de ludothèque
donc on réduit notre surface de stockage
donc on doit séparer d'une partie de la
collection est donc quoi vous allez
retrouver à peu près à peu près 1000
jeux ici à vendre à l'intérieur c'est
une véritable chasse au trésor qui se
joue grandeur nature on y retrouve des
jeux brader pour tous les âges et il
faut avoir la main heureuse pour
dénicher son jeu favori est jo du délit
il faut absolument je le trouve celui-ci
côté du ce matin
préjugés après si on n'a pas joué pour
faire autre chose la collection est si
vaste qu'elle pourrait même faire
plaisir à un collectionneur très
pointilleux il ya des jeux comme
celui-là xps 15z qui est un jeu vendu
sur ebay à 150 euros parce que pour des
collectionneurs ce qui n'a pas été
réédité
je suis là il n'est pas complet donc il
n'est pas sûr qu'il partira mais
peut-être qu'un collectionneur se dit ah
tiens j'aurais la pièce qui me manquera
et du coup il partira peut-être et si
vous êtes amateur de jeux de société ne
vous inquiétez pas malgré l'énorme
succès de cette brocante la maison des
jeux de touraine conserve près de 3000
titres
rendez vous désormais à l'espace
toulouse lautrec aux rives du cher